it's Thursday October 20th I'm Mary and
you're watching gamespot news the place
to watch every trailer that came out
because that's all that came out in the
news today bunch of trailers we're going
to watch them circling first up we got
our first look at red dead redemption to
in a trailer released this morning let's
take a look the video doesn't tell us a
lot but we do get to look at the games
vastly improved graphics and some
gorgeous looking scenery in terms of
story we never really got a good look at
what appears to be the main character
one man who kind of sounds like Dutch
from the original red dead redemption
says listen to me
when the time comes you gotta run and
don't look back this is over there are
seven characters seen at the end of the
trailer which follows on from the
previous red dead redemption two teasers
that showed 7 cowboys red dead
redemption to has been announced for
playstation 4 and xbox one were you
hoping to see from red dead too next up
was a trailer for Nintendo and X or
should I say switch with only five
months to go before it launches a new
console in March 2017 today Nintendo
started to share details about the
highly-anticipated system which is
called Nintendo switch as rumored it's a
console handheld hybrid it uses
cartridges in the home the Nintendo
switch sits in a Nintendo switch dock
that connects to TV you can then lift
the system out of the dock and will
instantly transition into a portable
mode the detachable controllers that sit
on either side of the Nintendo switch
are called joy con controllers you can
attach these joy con controllers onto
the system itself or a grip accessory
alternatively they can be used
wirelessly the trailer also showcased
some of the games on the Nintendo switch
such as what appears to be a version of
Skyrim and NBA 2k as well as the legend
of zelda breath of the wild and mario
kart finally there was a bit of a game
that kind of looked like a new 3d Mario
hmm Nintendo also shared a list of some
of the publishers developers and
middleware partners that are working
with Nintendo on the switch including
some of the biggest players in gaming
like Activision Bethesda bandai namco
Electronic Arts TV saw you get it you
can see the full list on gamespot the
Nintendo switch is slated to launch in
March 2017 it will be able to play the
upcoming Zelda breath of the wild
speaking of Zelda breath the wild guess
what we got new gameplay up today take a
look new videos of Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild have appeared showing
off impressive weather effects a number
of areas in the game world and
activities such as cooking the videos
seem to be unlisted on Nintendo's
official youtube page but links to them
have been found and posted online the
first video shows off a serene green
field but the weather slowly takes a
turn for the worst first shower rain and
then a full-blown thunderstorm the
second video is focused on exploration
and the game world we get to see link
running around crumbled cathedrals
climbing trees leaping into lakes and
sailing around using a makeshift raft
the third video is combat focus with
link using his trusty bow and arrows to
take out enemies from a distance getting
up close to do damage with a club and
taking on a giant stone golem with bombs
and you know what else he cooks it
starts with link hunting boars catching
fish and chopping down a tree to start a
fire and then putting all his
ingredients into a pot it looks like
there's going to be plenty to do in
breadth of the wild breath of the wild
is coming to Wii U and switch in 2017 so
those are the trailers we wanted you to
see today but you're going to want to
check back tomorrow for game spots top
five new stories of the week I'll see
them